[Music]
all right so my talk is called future
proofing yourself in the reinvention
revolution
how many of you have personal Brands
raise your hand
okay see about like a quarter of you
the truth is that all of us have
personal Brands you might not know it
you might not like it but the truth is
that we do have them
as Jeff Bezos says your brand is what
other people say about you when you're
not in the room
a lot of people get confused between
branding and marketing So today we're
going to learn about branding but not in
the way that you traditionally know it a
lot of people think that branding is is
marketing it's self-promotion but
today's talk is not about fonts or
Facebook it's about personal reinvention
we've seen so much change in the last
several years
so many companies are needing to
reinvent themselves faster and more
frequently than ever before but it's not
just companies it's us as individuals
that need to read Mentor cells
we're also seeing that uh you know the
amount of retention that's happening
we're seeing today that 20.6 of
companies have needed to in 2022 2022
needed to 20 have needed to reinvent
themselves in order to survive and
thrive and that's faster than ever
before
I'll tell you a story
so the reason why this is so important
to me is because I am someone that had
to reinvent myself reactively I didn't
do it proactively
and the reason I'm here today is to give
you some lessons and some some insights
on how to be more proactive in your
reinvention
almost a decade ago I was salima 1.0
I was traveling the world I was working
for an International Development Bank
and all over Latin America working with
banks working with governments and I
also had a side hustle working with a
Silicon Valley company called Elance
does anyone know Elance
it then became Elance odesk and then it
merged and became upwork
and I I was basically trying to teach
entrepreneurs how to build remote teams
we had a partnership with wework it was
a lot of fun
however after I pivoted out of my my day
job and I was working with Elance and
then I also started this digital
marketing agency with which was the
HubSpot reseller agency I thought I had
everything I wanted I was like 27 years
old my life seemed really good
but one day all of that started drying
up
I got laid off from both those jobs my
house had a fire that I just purchased
and everything my entire life was in
shambles and what people might know as a
life quake
has anyone experienced that before
so
that was really hard because I was being
reactive about it and I didn't really
you I felt some Whispers I felt some
itches I kind of felt my inside voice
telling me you know maybe you need to
make a change there are people telling
me maybe you need to make a pivot and I
was like I'm comfortable I'm gonna stay
right here
then I evolved into Selena 2.0 after I
recovered from that crisis which I'll
explain some tools and how I did that in
a minute I was now teaching design
thinking I was an entrepreneurship at
Johns Hopkins University I was working
with the World Bank on how do we solve
problems such as food Security in the
Middle East and North Africa with
refugees and I was looking at things
like Hydroponics aquaponics aeroponics
vertical farming 3D printing
and insect farming and
it felt like my life had gotten better
and I recovered from that that big life
quake
however I was also speaking around the
world and I was you know it seemed
really great but I wasn't living my my
life purpose and so even though I was
really passionate about entrepreneurs I
felt like I wasn't directly making the
impact I wanted to make even though I
was teaching it I was working with it at
the research level I felt like I was
missing that direct impact
and so that being said you know branding
the first thing you want to do is you
want to craft your positioning there was
something that was misaligned about my
branding because I really loved
entrepreneurship but then I was trying
to do all this other stuff and there was
some misalignment so people were like
what do you do you do so many things and
we see that today do any of you wear
multiple hats where you're kind of like
people are confused uh what are you an
expert at why should people hire you and
so I was one of those people were really
confused and so I learned the importance
of being very clear with my positioning
and when I say positioning it's not
necessarily where have I been in the
past a lot of times we're like okay
let's look at our LinkedIn and look at
it like a CV or a resume or We Are Who
we've been in the past but positioning
is using your hero story from your past
or taking parts of your past but who do
you want to be and position yourself
towards that future version of yourself
good example is that when I was writing
my book or when I finished writing my
book I was looking for endorsements and
I reached out to lots of people I
pitched to all kinds of people including
Seth Godin Ariana Huffington Adam Grant
and they responded within a few minutes
some of them which surprised me and the
reason is because I had a personal brand
I developed when I decided to become an
author
one of the first things I learned was
that you don't just put your book on
Amazon and be successful you have to
start from day one marketing yourself
branding yourself building your platform
not just when the book is done
and so uh so yeah having that personal
brand really really helped and and
another example is you don't have to be
you know it's not just the famous people
another example is uh you know my
hairdresser Ginger she is a curly hair
expert so she Brands herself as like the
nation's capitals curly hair expert
everyone knows here if you have curly
hair in Washington DC
and so there's something that's unique
about her she's really on her Niche and
and so really knowing what's different
about you and what's desired by other
people is the first step when you're
trying to put together your brand and
your positioning
and going back to this concept of
desired and different here I have a
framework that you'll see it's in my
book but essentially you want to be
non-obvious what's that thing that's not
just desired by other people but
different that thing that's compelling
that thing that's unique and the example
here is I don't know if any of you know
that Tick Tock quesadilla that was up
during the pandemic yeah
where you fold the quesadilla into into
four quarters there's like four quarters
and you fold it up and it went viral on
Tick Tock during the pandemic when
people are at home cooking but it's
basically the reason it was so it went
viral was that it was non-obvious all
the ingredients were the same as a
regular quesadilla but it was more than
ordinary it wasn't dull it wasn't
strange or odd but it was non-obvious
and so our goal is when we're
positioning ourselves to be non-obvious
one way to go about doing that when
you're figuring out how to position
yourself is doing a 100 coffee challenge
sometimes we think we know who we are
how we want to Brand ourselves but the
best way to really go about that process
especially if you're trying to figure
out who do I want to become in the
future sometimes we can be lost as to
like who will I be in three to five
years and we can be so stuck in our
grind in our day-to-day that it's
sometimes hard to know who should we
become you know that it's important to
reinvent yourself more regularly and
more frequently than before but you're
not really sure who that next version of
yourself is
and so one thing that I recommend and
that I did for myself was I would do
these 100 coffee challenges
in fact when I lost those two jobs and I
went on this Eat Pray self-love trip
when my house burnt down to I went to
India to Thailand to Bali when it came
back I'm Canadian I got denied entry
into the United States and I had two
weeks the immigration officer gave me
he's like nope you don't get 180 days
you get two weeks to figure out your
situation
so I went between two organizations that
I knew I could probably get a job and a
Visa if I worked really really hard and
I was setting up eight to ten coffees a
day I had two weeks to figure this out
in Washington DC
and within those two weeks I got two
offers and one of them was that
Hydroponics work with the World Bank
the country coffee challenge I've also
applied with my book when I got stuck in
the early stages of writing my book I
got some advice to do some interviews
and I was like let me take this to the
next level let me do a 100 coffee
Challenge and what I found was I
interviewed 100 people for the book
which is amazing it led to so many
collaborations and it got me to like
book tours and it helped me incredibly
but I also learned a lot about myself
oftentimes it wasn't we think that we
can just go within and I was you know I
was in India I was doing all this yoga
ayurveda meditation I'm like I I can
discover myself myself but what I
discovered through the 100 coffee
challenge was that other people were
finding me and they were seeing me how I
was showing up in that moment
second point is you want to position
yourself intentionally
and this is not about self-promotion
it's really about how are you desired
and different what's distinct about you
and leaning into that owning that
salima 3.0 yes to the tedx telling my
3.0 decided to own her passion in her
her love to help entrepreneurs and when
the pandemic happened that accelerated
that whole process a lot of my friends
and colleagues were stuck at home and
they were struggling with their
businesses they were trying to figure
out how do I make my business work
online and that's when I stepped in and
said you know what I'm not going to just
coach them and give them some advice and
mentorship I want to become the team
behind the scenes to these entrepreneurs
and that's when I created my current
business Ripple impact
I also launched the book and wanted to
go around the world and impact as many
people as possible and that became my
brand today
that's a picture from last month my team
in Colombia and then my team in Pakistan
in January
and my third point is you want to
reinvent yourself constantly listen to
that inner voice don't wait until you
have a life Quake don't wait until your
house burns down or you lose that job
really think about who you want to
become do that 100 coffee Challenge and
be really proactive about that
reinvention process
Madonna is a great example of someone
who reinvents herself every time she
releases a new album she changes her
fashion style her hair even her husband
sometimes
so we are living in this reinvention
revolution after you go through that
initial life Quake like I did when my
house burnt down or other times I've
gone through a lot I've you know been
divorced I've lost my mom at the age of
16. uh when you go through that it gets
easier you'll still go through these
reinventions but when you have one
really really hard life Quake it gets
easier to get through the rest it's not
it's not easy but it's easier
and kind of like you see here from the
room to the vacuum cleaner to the to the
Roomba you don't have to change
significantly but there's different
iterations we're not onions trying to
appeal to the core we're like ripples
we're constantly evolving and we have to
keep up with that before the world's or
circumstances dictate that
and the three take three key takeaways
is first you want to craft your
positioning position yourself
intentionally and then reinvent yourself
constantly
who is salima 4.0 I'm still figuring
that out I'm here at lead learning how
to be a better leader from a company
that's growing and I'm doing another 100
coffee challenge so if you want to grab
virtual coffee happy to talk to you and
you never know what comes from that but
I know it's a great way to to discover
ourselves and figure out who do we want
to be in the future and how do we
accelerate that
and that's it thank you
[Applause]
[Music]